so he's got weight in his bass there's
nothing there's no room but when he goes
to throw the punch you see the space hey
do you guys see that so I don't want to
go that way so I'm going to turn my head
you see that he goes to lift a punch and
I push that elbow over and he's gonna
want to come back right to hit me
boom you got it say he goes ain't good
here and he goes to punch and I'm
looking here I'm trying to get deeper
than his shoulders so if I don't get
deeper than his shoulder line do you see
see where his shoulders are you see that
plane same plane is my face he's gonna
knock the hell out of me but if I can
get closer to his feet than away from
his shoulders that punch isn't gonna do
what he thinks it's gonna do so I'm
coming over here for this truck he comes
back to punch and I'm going on the other
way see I'm doing that same thing
getting deeper than his shoulder line
and I think the other way he's going to
come back to punch again this one I just
got a cover up that will be my trap
[Music]
again so it's more about moving my body
than leaving my body here and trying to
go like this
got it I'm moved I'm I'm moving
deviating deviating deviating deviate
[Music]
so looking at it conceptually so RiRi
did with the line of attack right and
then the second one when he gives you
the space right okay now watch what I'm
doing with him so he has two choices
he's either gonna put his weight on the
mat or he's gonna put his weight on me
do you see that so if he puts his weight
on me it's harder for me to move me but
I can move him you see that so you keep
your weight on me and it'll be like
you're on a foam roller okay and that's
what I'm trying to do here
just get your weight back on me bring it
on me that's it right you see how I'm
doing that so I'm moving under him to
get this okay he comes back
[Music]
if he doesn't put his weight on me his
weights on his knees then I have lots of
room to move me do you see that but I
can still move him by manipulating his
extremity so rather than leaving that
foot doing nothing and I just go for
this proceeding pass use it to torque
him do you see that and then you got him
to move so he's he he's gonna realize at
this point all right too much space so
he might go back to the other one he's
gonna put his weight on me
and I use that to move him okay so
instead of panicking because he's got
his weight on you use it like your nurse
plate and he can't get stabilized okay
but you have to have your internal
organization so you're not getting
segmented okay you're look you like a
solid thing that's rolling him okay try